Do you want me to show you that Muhammad
is your God? The other god you worship?
>> I don't worship Muhammad. I follow him.
>> No, you actually worship him even though
you deny it. Here, I'll prove it to you.
Is submitting to Allah an act of worship
when you submit to him?
>> And what is Islam?
>> Submitting to God.
>> No. The Quran says Islam is to submit to
Allah and Muhammad equally.
>> You didn't even know that.
>> We believe that. We believe that
whatever Muhammad said came from
>> what I asked you
>> the Holy Spirit.
>> No, God forbid. Don't ever insult the
Holy Spirit. But let me repeat again.
Islam is perfectly submitting to
Muhammad, not just Allah.
>> I mean, he's dead. So,
>> so you're saying he's dead. That means
you just buried the Quran because the
Quran says unless you come to Muhammad
and he prays for you, you will find no
forgiveness. So how does Allah forgive
you now that Muhammad's dead?
That chapter 4:64 of the Quran, it says
had they come to you and ask Allah for
forgiveness and you prayed for
forgiveness, they would find Allah most
forgiving. So how can I come to Muhammad
and pray to Allah and have Muhammad pray
for me so Allah show me mercy if he's
dead? So you're saying the Quran is
useless now?
>> No, I'm saying right now in this
physical world he's dead. But isn't the
Quran for all Muslims at all times to
the end of the age? So how can I follow
when it says had they come to you
Muhammad and they prayed and asked Allah
to forgive and you prayed for their
forgiveness then Allah would be most
merciful to them. How can I obey that
command now that Muhammad is dead?
>> I mean didn't you say that people can
pray for you when they're dead because
they're still alive in the spirit?
That's what I wanted to hear. So that's
why your Muslims say you can still obey
that command by going to the grave of
your prophet and greeting your prophet
and asking him to forgive you. So you're
okay going to the grave of Muhammad and
talking to a dead man and asking
>> that they say that's
>> no it isn't. I have the statements from
Ali Abu Talib as well as from
[clears throat]
cited by Ib Kir saying that the Muslims
did it shortly after Muhammad died.
Where are you getting sherk from?
>> You can't ask for forgiveness from
anyone except for God.
>> Friend, chapter 4 64 says you got to go
to Muhammad and he's got to ask for
forgiveness for you when you ask Allah
to forgive and that's when Allah will
show you mercy. 46 to go to him. Read
it. 464.
>> It's right there.
>> One second.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And we did not send any messenger
except to be obeyed by by permission of
Allah.
And
>> if when they wronged themselves, they
had come to you, oh Muhammad, and asked
forgiveness of Allah. And the messenger
had asked forgiveness for them. Why do
you go to Muhammad?
To do what? To kiss the black stone
together or to dance shani? Why do you
go to Muhammad there?
>> They had come to you, oh Muhammad, and
then asked forgiveness of Allah.
>> And what must he do?
>> He asked for you.
>> Then Allah will be merciful, right?
>> They would have found Allah accepting of
repentance and merciful.
>> But now Muhammad is dead. So how can I
now go to Muhammad and Muhammad pray and
I pray? Allah would be most willing to
forgive me. He's dead, right?
>> I mean, on the day of judgment.
[snorts]
>> What?
>> This is not talking about the day of
judgment. It's talking about the time of
your prophet.
>> Okay. But he's not here right now.
>> So, you're telling me then the Quran is
garbage because this part of the Quran
is useless. I can't do it.
>> No, that's not true.
>> How do I obey that command in the Quran?
So it's saying when they wronged
themselves, they had come to you, oh
Muhammad.
>> Yeah. To you. Come to you.
>> Okay. This was when he was alive.
>> Okay. So now he's dead. So this verse is
now useless, right?
>> Not necessarily. And as
>> then how do I obey this command?
>> What's that?
>> How do I obey this command?
>> Like I said, the day of judgment.
>> It doesn't say day of judgment. Why are
you adding to the
>> Yeah. No, you're right. Because at the
day of judgment, no
guys,
>> it doesn't say day of judgment.
>> So, so we believe, like I said, Prophet
Muhammad intercedes for us on the day of
the day of judgment.
>> Forget day of judgment. This is talking
about now. Now, stop going to the
future. Change the subject. How do I go
to Muhammad and have him pray for me
now? So when I ask Allah forgive me,
Allah will forgive me. I want to know
how can I do that verse now?
Read chapter 9 verse 103 for me. Go to
chapter there's another one. Chapter 9
vers 10.
>> This is also saying that this is for any
prophet. This is for any messenger.
>> No, it's talking about there is no
prophet after Muhammad. It's talking
about Muhammad coming to him.
>> Though look, it says
>> don't change the subject, man. Go to
9103.
>> We're on the same passage and we did not
any messenger.
>> Who is the messenger they go to? If they
came to you, you're telling me that's
Jesus.
>> To any messenger.
>> No. If they come to you, who's the you?
>> And we did not send any messenger.
>> Finish it before I send the black stone
to
>> except to be obeyed by
>> and finish it the rest of it.
>> And if when they wronged themselves,
they had come to you.
>> Who's you? Moses.
>> Oh, Muhammad. He was the messenger. Stop
changing the subject cuz you just said
Muhammad is the final prophet. He's the
messenger. So how do I come to him? Is
Allah going to send me another messenger
that I go to right now?
>> No, he's the final messenger.
>> Okay. Earlier you said he's the final
prophet, not the final messenger. I'm
glad you just contradicted yourself.
Good.
>> No, I know. I looked it up. He is the
final prophet.
>> Oh, you have to look it up. So now that
Muhammad is the final messenger, there
is no messenger that's going to come
after him for me to go to. So, how do I
go to the final messenger Muhammad to
have him pray that Allah forgive me if
he's dead?
>> Just by asking Allah. And I'm sure
>> that's not what the verse says. They had
come to you.
>> How am I going to go to Muhammad and
have him pray for me? So when I pray, to
Allah will forgive me. He's dead. So how
do I carry out that command?
>> I don't know.
>> Exactly. So now not you're being honest.
Now go to chapter 9 verse 103.
>> 93.
>> Yes.
Now guys, uh we return and I want to
just ask you guys, you still want me to
do part four responding to Ray Comfort?
Guys, put a one if you want me to do it.
Lord willing, I can do it immediately
when I finish this or I'll go at 10:30
p.m. Eastern Standard Time. Let me know
cuz right now it's 8:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time. When I'm done, I can
immediately go and do that or do it at
10:30 p.m. Eastern Standard Time. So,
let me know. Do you guys want me to do
it 10:30 p.m. scheduled or right when I
finish this? Tell me right when you
finish this or 10:30 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time. Let me know.
This was impromptu.
>> Okay.
>> Take Muhammad from their wealth.
>> Slowly, slowly so we can hear it out
loud. Okay. Chapter 9 [clears throat]
verse 103.
>> Take, oh Muhammad, from their wealth a
charity by which you purify them and
cause them increase and invoke Allah's
blessing upon them.
>> Okay, before you go on. Okay guys, more
said 10:30. It's going to be 10:30 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time. So that means in
two hours from now. Pray for me now. One
more time. Read chapter 9 verse 103.
Take, oh Muhammad, from their wealth a
charity by which you purify them and
cause them increase and invoke Allah's
blessing upon them. Indeed, your
invocations and reassurance for them and
Allah is hearing and knowing. Okay. And
now this verse says that uh Muhammad
your prophet takes alms from the Muslims
and then he prays for them and they will
be purified and forgiven. Right here,
let me get let me put on the screen so
people can see here. Chapter 9 vers 103
guys. It will be 10:30 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time. We're going to stay with
the same time. 9103. Here you go. 9103.
So they can see what we're reading. Now
watch. Take arms of their wealth
wherewith thou mayest purify them. You
may purify them and make them grow and
pray for them. Lo, thy prayer is an
assuagement for them. Allah's hearer and
knower. So here I'm told, let me read
another version.
So I give you multiple versions. Here
I'm told that Muhammad takes charity
from a Muslim and when he does, he'll
purify them, cleanse them, make them
grow, and he prays for them. and his
prayer will grant me security here 9:103
take saddak alms from their wealth in
order to purify them and sanctify them
with it and invoke Allah for them so now
verily your invocation source of
security for them now let me ask you a
question here it says if a Muslim comes
and gives Muhammad charity he takes it
and he prays that prayer is a source of
security for the Muslim and when he
takes the charity from them. He purifies
them. Now that Muhammad is dead, how can
I go to Muhammad, give him alms so he
can pray for me so I can have security
from his prayer and be purified from my
sin now that he's dead? How do I follow
this command?
>> Just by giving charity.
>> It didn't say that Muhammad has to take
the charity from me. Read it carefully.
He has to take it from me and then he
prays for me. How can I have Muhammad
take charity from me and pray for me so
I'm guaranteed security from Allah and
purification now that he's dead?
>> We don't need to give Prophet Muhammad
charity.
>> That's not what the verse says. Allah
stuck for Allah. I keep reading the
verse and you keep correcting Allah.
>> I'm saying Allah say
>> you can't you can't how are you going to
give him charity if he
>> That's why I'm asking you don't why
that's the problem. Why you need to
leave Islam?
>> Why is it a problem? Because here it
says Muhammad is the one who will pray
for you to guarantee security for you
and he will purify you by taking your
charity. But now that Muhammad is dead,
how can I know that I am secure and
purified cuz he's not here to pray for
me or take charity from me?
>> Okay. And then the next verse after that
says
>> you can read five million verses. I
still want this one. One right next to
it says, "Do they not know that Allah is
the one who accepts repentance from his
servants and
>> receive?"
>> How does he accept it?
>> And receives
>> that it is Allah who is accepting of
repentance.
>> How does he accept it? By you going to
Muhammad, he will accept it. What are
you not getting?
>> What do you mean? I don't need to go to
Prophet Muhammad.
>> Yes, you do. 9103 just said it and 464
said it.
>> This is of the time of the prophet.
>> So that's my question now that he's
dead. So you're saying these verses are
now garbage. They're useless. They have
no
>> meaning that this is what they went.
>> Oh, so these verses are now useless.
They have no meaning today.
>> No, it just shows that people used to
give Muhammad charity. Charity.
>> I'm going to ask the question one more
time that I got to send you because
you're not getting it. One more time. I
want to see if you get it.
>> Yeah. I mean, right now, sure. It's not
useful.
>> So these verses are useless. They have
no meaning for Muslims today.
>> I guess.
>> Okay. Okay, you guessed. Now I want to
ask you another question. Did you read
the verse carefully? Who purifies you?
>> Indeed.
Charity by which you from their wealth a
charity by which you purify them. And
>> who purifies them?
>> Increase
by which you purify them. Who purifies
them?
>> Yeah. So he purifies them.
>> Who's he?
>> The prophet Muhammad.
>> Thank you. Now guys, you heard it from
his own mouth. Yeah. The prophet
purifies them. That's why you're a
Muhammadan and you worship Muhammad
because you just said Muhammad purifies
you of sin.
Thank you. We got you recorded. And you
still think you don't worship Muhammad.
You're a pagan.
>> I don't.
>> You just said Muhammad purifies them.
Purification means purify them of sin.
Something only God does. You ascribed it
to Muhammad. You committed sh because
your God made you commit sh. Good job.
>> That that's that's a miracle. That's one
of his miracles.
>> That's the miracle that Allah made you a
pagan Muhammad in committing sh. That's
the miracle.
>> Now you're being sarcastic.
>> No, it's true. You're not waking up.
You're not seeing it, man. It's okay.
Anyway, so hey,
>> very carefully with an open mind.
>> Yes. Okay. My mind is very open.
>> So So Jesus could purify you.
>> Yeah. Because Jesus is God in the flesh.
We don't think Muhammad is God in the
flesh. So tell me Muhammad is God in the
flesh like you believe Jesus is God in
the flesh.
>> No, I don't. I don't believe that. So
why are you comparing Muhammad to Jesus?
Jesus is God in the flesh because he's
he
>> I wanted to say that I any prophet could
purify somebody.
>> No, no, that's not what it says. Only
God purifies and forgives. That's in
your Quran 3 verse 135 and it's in my
Bible. But
>> let me grab my charger. Do you want to
take like a five minute break?
>> No, what we'll do is come back some
other time because it's already two
hours.
>> Yeah, it's been two hours.
>> Let's do something this week. You're a
good guy. I like you. I'm sorry. Sorry,
I'm got to be heated with you because
I'm hoping the Holy Spirit will shake
you. But I have to do another stream in
two hours. I need a break. So, Lord
willing, contact me this week. We'll do
another one. All right.
>> Okay. Sounds good.
>> Take care, buddy.
>> Bye.
>> Okay, brethren. Pray for him. Suab,
pray for him.
Pray that he'll go back and relisten to
this because if he listens to it by the
conviction of the Holy Spirit with an
open heart, his foundation will be
rocked and destroyed.